- À la gare centrale
de Varsovie...
(bruit d'enfant)
... on fait ce qu'on peut pourur
donner un semblant de vie
normale à ces enfants.
Des petits ukrainiens qui ont
fui les bombes et qui ne savent
toujours pas oùfinir
par se poser, comme l'explique
Kuba, un bénévole.
- En général, ils restent
quelques dizaines d'heures.
Entre 10-12 heures et
une journée et demie. Certains
sont tellement épuisés qu'ils
n'ont pas la force de...
de se lever à 4h du matin pour
prendre le train qui va à
Berlin.
- Certains espèrent trouver
un logement dans la région.
D'autres attendent un train vers
une autre ville d'Europe où
ils ont des proches.
- "On ne veut pas aller vers un
autre pays", dit Cristina, qui a
fui Kiev. "On veut rentrer chez
nous. S'îl vous plaît,
Vladimir Poutine, arrêtez
ce conflit."
Ici, la plupart des réfugiés
n'arrivent qu'avec une valise.
On leur On leur On leur On leur,
de l'eau et des produits
sanitaires.
Uliana, qui n'a que 12 ans,
avait entendu parler de
la Première et de la Deuxième
Guerre mais ne pensait
jamais en vivre une, une guerre.
- C'est pour accueillir
un certain nombre de
ces réfugiés que Justin Trudeau,
en visite à Varsovie, ann
117 millions de dollars
pour accélérer le traitement
des demandes.
JUSTIN TRUDEAU, premier ministre
du Canada
- On est en train out
ce qu'on peut, le plus
rapidement possible, pour
ramener le plus grand nombre
de gens possible dans un bref
délai.
- Mais cens,
s'ils cognent aux portes
des ambassades canadiennes,
se font référer à un site
internet du gouvernement pour
remplir une demande. Difficile,
e poser des questions
précises.
- Les gens ne devraient pas
se rendre seulement à la mission
à Varsovie ou à Berlin pour
avoir de l'aide, pour avoirleurr
au Canada. On veut qu'ils
puissent appliquer de partout
en Europe, où ils se trouvent.
- Le président polonais, qui a
déjà accueilli dans son pays
1,5 million d'Ukrainiens,
demande à Justin Trudeau
un processus simple pour
les réfugiés.
- Justin Trudeau termine don
avec la Pologne, sa visite
de 4 pays en Europe.
Un voyage marqué par
la solidarité, des promesses,
mais pas de développement ou de
percée majeure qui
vraiment changer à court terme
le sort des Ukrainiens qui
fuient leur pays.
ICI Laurence Martin,
Radio-Canada, Varsovie